all right ladies and gentlemen the
meeting will come to order hello
everyone I'm Stephen Michael Jones the
new chairman and interim CEO of Daily
Journal Corporation as of the end of
March 2022. I'm here today at our Los
Angeles headquarters with an individual
who really needs no introduction the
legendary Mr Charles T Munger who until
last year served as Daily Journal
corporations chairman for many decades
I'm grateful that Charlie who remains a
director on our board has agreed to join
us today
I also want to acknowledge and express
our gratitude that Mr Munger continues
to manage Daily Journal corporations
considerable portfolio of marketable
Securities and at no cost to the
business I might add so thank you
Charlie
over the years this annual shareholder
meeting has become an increasingly
popular event given it's been a unique
and wonderful opportunity to hear from
and ask questions of Mr Munger
I recognize this is why many of you are
joining us today and so my goal is to go
through our formal business as quickly
as possible without sounding too much
like an Auctioneer
um
I also want to say that we really wanted
to return to an in-person format for
this year with a with an audience of our
shareholders actually here with us and
with the other members of our board Mary
Collin and John Frank joining us on
stage however for health and safety
reasons we opted to err on the side of
caution again this year uh to and do
another round of the online approach
um that we've followed over the pandemic
I I recognize we're all done with covid
but covet doesn't quite appear done uh
with all of us
so before I turn things over to Becky
quick of CNBC to moderate the Q a we'll
now proceed to the formal business of
the annual meeting Michelle Stevens
Executive Vice President and Secretary
of this meeting and Ellen Ireland is
inspector of Elections Ellen will you
please report the number of shares
represented at this meeting
on December 16 2022 the record date
fixed by the board of directors for
determining the shareholders entitled to
vote today there were 1 million 377 026
shares of common stock of its
Corporation outstanding I have a list of
the shareholders who were of record of
that date certified by the corporation's
transfer agent at Kennedy Trust Company
I also have an affidavit certifying the
completion of the mailing of the notice
of this meeting the proxy card and the
2022 annual report along with a prepaid
postage return envelope to the
shareholders
the total number of shares represented
by proxy at this meeting is 849
758 which is more than a majority of
voting power of all outstanding common
stock of the corporation and the meeting
May proceed I will attach the affidavits
to the minutes of this meeting and have
a copy of the minutes of the last annual
meeting
thank you a majority of the voting power
of the corporation is represented at
this meeting and this meeting is ready
for the transaction of business
as the first order of business we will
act upon the first proposal which is the
election of a board of directors
four directors are to be elected at this
meeting and the following people have
been nominated and received the number
of votes and are thus elected to serve
Charles T Munger Mary Conlin John B
Frank Stephen mahel Jones the inspector
of Elections has tabulated the vote
the nominees have received the following
number of votes Charles T Munger 428
537.
Mary conlon 516 625.
John B Frank
573 419 Stephen Michael Jones
543 229.
since each of the nominees has received
the number of votes required for his or
her election as director I declare that
each has been elected director to serve
for the next year until his or her
successor has been elected and qualified
the second proposal is the ratification
of the selection of the independent
registered public accounting firm the
audit committee and the board of
directors have selected Baker Tilly U.S
LLP for this fiscal year and the
ratification requires a vote of the
majority of the shares represented at
this meeting the inspector of Elections
has tabulated the vote
four 846 716 against
1097 abstain
1945 proposal 2 is hereby declared
approved by this meeting
the third proposal concerns The Advisory
note on executive compensation
two-toe our CFO and I are the only
executive officers of the company and
our compensation is described in the
proxy statement the approval requires a
vote of the majority of the shares
listed represented at this at this
meeting the inspector of Elections has
tabulated the vote and the following
votes have been cast four
six hundred eight thousand nine hundred
and three against
1296 abstain
3005. proposal three is hereby declared
approved by this meeting
fourth proposal concerns The Advisory
note on the frequency of the advisory
vote on approval of executive
compensation the option of one year two
years and or three years that receives
the highest number of votes cast will be
the frequency for the advisory vote on
executive compensation selected by the
shareholders the inspector of Elections
has tabulated the vote and the following
votes have been cast one year 185 735
two years four thousand two hundred and
eighty one three years four hundred and
sixteen thousand three hundred and
twenty one accordingly the stockholders
have elected hold the vote on executive
compensation once every three years
since there is not any further business
to be brought before the meeting the
meeting is adjourned we'll now trans
transition to the Q a once again with
Becky quick of CNBC serving as our
moderator
thank you in advance Becky uh I
recognize most questions will be for
Charlie and I'll likely answer the
occasional question if it's specifically
about Daily Journal or Journal
Technologies thanks everyone over to you
Becky Steven thank you very much and
welcome everyone we got a a great number
of questions that came in and I've tried
to sort through as many as I could we'll
go through as many of these questions as
we can during the session but first of
all Charlie thank you for taking the
time today the first question that we
have comes from Ryan fusaro and his
question is related to journal
Technologies he says can you give an
update on the company's new CEO Stephen
myhill Jones he was appointed as interim
CEO nearly one year ago how's he
performing and when will a decision be
made on selecting a permanent CEO
well the answer is
Steve chose his own titles coming in
and we'll change whenever he wants to
change it how's that
that sounds fair enough yeah no I
Stephen
uh you know I uh yeah I'll say that when
we were in discussions a year ago
um I told Charlie that I was committed
to ensure the success of the business
but that I wasn't sure I would be the
right long-term CEO and I had incomplete
information at the time and I thought it
was important that I have the
optionality to hire someone better
suited or promote from within if we
discovered that'd be a better path and
um you know I I found it and helped grow
a geography software company
with no background in publishing or the
legal and Court sector
um and what I can say now is that the
parallels between the software company I
built and journal technology is our are
remarkable and I believe I can add value
um I like the business and the potential
for it so
um I expect we'll have Clarity on our
long-term approach uh sometime later
this year okay Stephen thank you the
second question comes in and it's in
regards to Capital allocation this is
from Paul in Linwood Michigan Paul Pham
in the past year you've just in the past
you've described daily journal's unique
position of being a newspaper which
generated enough excess cash in the past
to invest in an equity portfolio now
it's fastest growing subsidiary Journal
Technologies accounts for a large part
of the company's earnings is the
technology business a natural area to
allocate excess capital for the best
return on equity for the company has
gone off oh can you hear me Charlie I'll
keep talking I can't hear her one two
three four five I'll test this out maybe
you guys can play me I don't know if
there's a a voice of God you could play
to the floor there but I'll keep talking
in the hopes that Charlie can pick up on
this and Charlie just let me know when
you do hear this
this is a question again
sounds like they're not hearing folks I
don't know in the control room if you
guys have any ideas about what's
happening
again this is the annual meeting for the
Daily Journal shareholders meeting we
have a lot of questions that have come
in for Charlie Munger and we're going to
be getting to those questions as soon as
we can get the audio fixed for this
um
sounds like Becky we can hear you over
uh someone's brought a tablet over and
we can hear you over the tablet for the
time being okay Stephen thank you
Charlie I'll just wrap up I don't know
where you this got cut off but this is
from Paul Pham he was asking about
capital capital allocation and he's just
wondering if the technology business is
a natural area to allocate excess
capital for the best return on equity
for the company
how should we think about or how does
the current investment manager think
about investing in the equity portfolio
in relation to reinvesting in growing
areas of the business or share BuyBacks
the business or share BuyBacks
well it's all very simple
we made a lot of extra money out of the
publishing business and it's heyday
and that was about 30 million dollars
and that was a
all made in the Foreclosure boom
and of course in the old days we had a
information Monopoly on publishing the
appellate courts decisions
daily and newsprint
and the internet came along it destroyed
our
our position our circulation went way
down and so forth so we've had a drastic
change in Good Fortune in our publishing
business
and
Steve actually ran the small software
company you know
in in Canada for years and years and
years which is quite similar to what
general Technologies does
and
so that's how we got together
the future of this business is not in
the publishing side it's on the
it's on the general technology side
and
the good news is that we're in a huge
Market because all the courts of the
world are in the Stone Age still in
terms of automating with modern
technology
and so it's a big Market the bad news is
it's a long slowest log where you deal
with a lot of bureaucracies in response
to rfps
a request for proposals and it's just a
very slow difficult business so we got a
slow difficult business of chewing our
way into a huge Market that's not going
away
with one big competitor in it
and
and that's the future and
like many a Publishing Company
which use newsprint
uh
it's a miracle and then you survive
if you look in the small and mid-cap
edition of the value line books you'll
find there are two entries left one is
Gannett which used to own the Monopoly
newspaper and I don't know 50 60 100
different cities
and the executives used to ride around
in giant airplanes and be treated like
Lords of England when they went to
Publishers convention
and every newspaper publisher that you
know was It was a
hugely powerful in his own community so
they're like the Lords of England all
these publishers and now Mighty Genet is
just a pale shadow of itself
newspapers shrunk down to a tiny little
few and very limited assets and so forth
so there's been an unbelievable change
in the technology and competitive
outcomes in publishing ordinary
newspapers on newsprint and by and large
the safe rule is they're all dying it's
just in different states of near death
and so if this place has a future it's
in the general technology side
and that's a long slow grind and the
only reason we have a lot of marketable
Securities is we had the extra money and
we preferred the marketable Securities
to cash in the inflationary world
and so
and of course there's been a minor
miracle that we've got as much as we
have in the marketable Securities
because
our investments have done better than
average
as a follow-up so I'm the good news as
we survived so far and we've got some
Surplus wealth
and the bad news it's a long slow slog
ahead in the main future is in journal
Technologies
as a follow-up to that this is a related
question it comes from Gareth Moore in
Northern Ireland and maybe you can both
comment on this he says that given the
extended amount of time
that it will take to digitize the court
systems because of complexity risk and
bureaucracy and the fast-moving world of
software innovation
software how can shareholders be assured
that journal technology solution remain
Cutting Edge long enough to reward
shareholders and how do you think about
the risk of arriving in 2030 with a
great software business but which only
lasts a few years until it gets
disrupted by some new technology
sure I mean Steve would take that one
yeah
you know of course there are no
assurances
um and and at the same time you know I I
do have some background dealing with
this challenge because I did it for for
19 years with my former company
um and and we earned consistent and
appealing profits and I expect the model
is still working well for the folks who
acquired us
um you know I I think a key
responsibility is to get technology
change working for us and our customers
rather than against us
and it and it takes
Advanced planning and and investment to
engineer software
um with with with change uh over time in
mind and so it's inherently upgradable
and I think this model works works great
if you can establish a sufficient
licensee base to fund
that that proactive r d to evolve
products in a way that manages
technology change so that
um and it also needs to be highly
repeatable and and I think all of this
requires a mindset that enterprise
software development is an ongoing
process and and not a one-time event and
and and and so our our uh our customer
deployments
okay uh let me move on to another
question that comes from Gage Sanchez
um Gage writes in with a question for
for you Charlie two years ago during the
2021 yeah
let's try that
okay you've got the speaker there okay
so Gage Sanchez writes in and says two
years ago during the 2021 annual meeting
you said daily journals 350 stock was
selling way above the price that you
would pay for the new shares as I write
this Daily Journal trades for 305
dollars a share a 420 million dollar
market cap with a total Equity portfolio
value of over 310 million dollars debt
charges covered several times over by
the bank's dividends and journal
Technologies off financial statement
value in huge Market do you still hold
the same belief
same belief
well he accurately stated our
circumstances
and
we do have a lot of surplus wealth but
we need it to attack this big Market
the these courts
why would they gamble on a little
company with no not well worth the
courts that are letting the RFP
contracts
so we're we're using our our net worth
to help the business
but does that get at the question of
whether you'd buy this stock at 305 or
305.
well I don't buy it and I don't sell it
so
that's what the mongers have been doing
you know what
we now have audio
it's not a crazy evaluation considering
what everything else is selling for
these days
so I have no feeling that it's
almost foolishly high on some crazy
Mystique some people well it's a small
Berkshire and it'll double like rabbits
you know
and of course it's not a small Bircher
I'm 99 years old for Chrissy
that question mentioned the bank
dividends that that you all have at DJ
Co another
another person wrote in Norman Bergman
who asks Charlie Berkshire has unloaded
the bank stocks if it's not good enough
for Berkshire shareholders why is it
good for us
well
I might have a different idea
if you own Securities marketable
securities within a corporation
located in California you pay a huge
state in federal taxes if you sell
things at a big game
and that affects our willingness to sell
some of those Bank stocks I bought on
the bottom tick in the Foreclosure
crisis it literally was the bottom tick
and they're practically all gain so I
immediately give the government 40 some
percent of
everything we sell out of that out of
those Bank stocks so
and of course they're producing a taxi
the Dividends are almost tax-free
so based on what we would get if we sold
them and the return we're getting out of
the dividends it's not so bad for us
the answer is it's
we're not in a normal position
all factors considered we're willing to
hold them for a while and
there is a big disadvantage in in
Africa's huge layer of federal corporate
taxes and state taxes between us and any
money we make in a state like California
which is a very
business unfriendly state
it doesn't make people rushing to come
out and incorporate in California
m
M there are all kinds of states that
have no income taxes and deliberately
use
that lure to bring in corporations
California is trying to force its
wealthy people and its wealthy
corporations out of the state and I must
say it's working fine they're leaving
just one after now it's another
that's just
the way it is but
you know if we succeed in this software
business it will all come good in the
end
and if we fail we have a crutch under us
in our real estate and our Securities
which means we won't lose so much from
the president market price so it's not a
crazy thing to
to own now at the market valuation but
it's not cheap either
right
all right this next question comes from
Thomas Liney who says he's a longtime
Berkshire shareholder but a pretty
recent uh Daily Journal shareholder he
says well I know the Daily Journal is
not a mini Berkshire Idaho suspected
that there would be some shared
principles in the area of governance
specifically regarding the board of
directors I'm surprised to see such a
small ownership three of the five on
zero shares a fourth owns a hundred
shares Thomas says pretty unimpressive
doesn't suggest much alignment between
the board members and shareholders he
says he's not trying to be rude but he
thinks it's a fair question
well what happens is we used to have
Garen and Munger and we were the two
biggest shareholders and of course we'd
been partners for years and years
and we took no fees no no directors fees
no expenses no nothing
and so it was a very user-friendly
Berkshire type place
well Garen died finally at age 90 so and
and so now we're down to one last
survivor in the Old Guard and of course
we need a certain number of new
directors and our new directors are
pretty damn smart and they're all rich
by the way so it's still a very
Berkshire like board
a smart and Rich and
and thinking like a capitalist we still
we have that
I I I would add that you know while I
don't have Equity yet I'm I'm I'm
certainly Keen to participate in future
growth of the business
um what what should the timing of that
be with someone as new as me I I think
that's an interesting question
um Thomas I uh we'll work it out yeah
right right now I don't think that's
impacting my my driver decisions I I
already feel enormous skin in the game
that Mr Munger and the board entrusted
me to take the reins of the business is
something I take very seriously it's
really quite interesting to have a pile
of Securities and one interesting
activity in a very high-tech field
and with a lot of politics and travel
and
and difficulty in it but
it's a huge huge Market
and it isn't like there are a lot of
other people in it most of the big
corporations it would be our natural
competitors are
are places where they
they hate rfps and in other words one of
the reasons the business is good for us
is a lot of the big companies just hate
what we're doing
they want very easier money at that even
some standard Visa software just
repeated over and over again
they're spoiled
we're willing to Slug It Out of the mud
of all these little Consulting contracts
and that makes us have
really a few competitors in the field
Charlie since you brought up Rick Aaron
oh go ahead
no go ahead well since you brought up
Rick Aaron I want to get to this
question from ronit Pereira and Mumbai
who says your friend Rick Aaron passed
away about a year ago he was your
longtime friend and business partner for
several decades how was he as a person
as an investor and how do you remember
his legacy
well he was just terrific as a person an
investor and
I miss him terribly
of course
we were together for years and years and
years and we were poor together and that
creates a bonding
when we met uh in 1961
we were both
poor and struggling and Young
so we had a long ride together
and but all things end you know that's
that's the same that's the nature of The
Human Condition
get to a question from Lee uh just the
first name from this uh shareholder
wrote in a question about chat GPT and
artificial intelligence and the impact
on daily journals the daily journals
business model and civilization at large
says I'm not sure if you've tried to
converse with chat GPT given all the
rage in the news lately
briefly it's artificial intelligence
known as a language model it's trained
on trained on a large data set of texts
like books and articles what are your
thoughts on ai's impact on daily
journals business and more broadly our
civilization at Large
well
I think artificial intelligence is very
important
but is also a lot of crazy hype on the
subject
artificial intelligence is not going to
cure cancer it's not going to do
everything that we want done
and
and there's a lot of
nonsense in it too so
I regard it as a mixed blessing all this
artificial intelligence
some people have used it
in some things like Insurance
underwriting pretty well
but a lot of people try and use it in
ordinary things like
buying Office Buildings or something and
I think that's
way more I don't think it's going to
help anybody to buy an office building
not very much anyway
through through the lens of Daily
Journal Corporation AI is something that
we started uh experimenting with in the
summer uh in the summer for certain
types of writing of certain types of
Articles that's something we're
certainly tracking very closely I think
in terms of
um complex work I think it's a it's a
long way off uh but for many types of
activities
especially routine things I I think
we'll I think it'll be fascinating to
see how disruptive it is over a
relatively short time Horizon for for
many types of work and and activities
illness we had our big disruption when
the technology
kind of
severely
inadversely affected our publishing
business
and
we have our opportunity in this new
business but it's it's just a long tough
slog there's no short there's no rural
road to success in what we're doing
someone named Peter Ferlin wrote In from
Oakville Ontario and he had a question
that he asked he asked chat GPT to come
up with a question to ask you Charlie
and here's what chat GPT came up with Mr
Munger you've spoken about the
importance of avoiding mental biases and
decision making in your experience
what's the most challenging bias to
overcome and how do you personally guard
against it so I'd ask your answer to
that question and then what you think of
the question that GPT chat GPT wrote for
you
well what
if I had to name one factor that
dominates doing bad decisions it would
be what I call denial
if the truth is unpleasant enough
people kind of
their mind plays tricks on them and they
they think it it isn't really happening
and of course that causes enormous
destruction of business where people go
on throwing money into
the way they used to do things isn't
going to work at all well in the way the
world is now having changed
and
and if you want to an example of how
denial is affecting things
take the world of investment management
how many managers
are going to beat the indexes
all costs considered
I would say maybe five percent
to consistently be the averages
everybody else is living in a state of
extreme denial they're used to charging
big fees and so forth for stuff that
isn't doing their clients any good it's
a deep moral depravity
if some Widow comes to you if I hundred
thousand dollars and you charge your one
point a year for
and you could put her in the indexes
but you need the the one point and so
people just
charge some Widow you know
a considerable fee for worthless advice
and the whole profession is full of that
kind of denial
it's everywhere so
so I had to say
and I was I always quote demos on these
it's a long time ago democity that's 2
000 more than 2 000 years ago
and he said what people
wish is what they believe
think of how much of that goes on
and so it's of course it's hugely
important and you can just see it I
would say the agency costs and money
management
they're just so many billions it's
uncountable
and nobody can face it who wants to
keep your kids in school you need the
fees you need the brokerage questions
you need this or that so you do what's
good for you and bad for them
now I I don't think Berkshire does that
and I don't think we've Garen and I did
it as a Daily Journal Karen and I never
took a diamond salary or directors fees
or anything and if I have a business I
talk on my phone or use my car I don't
charge it in the Daily Journal that's
unheard of
it shouldn't be unheard of and it goes
on in Berkshire and it goes out in the
Daily Journal
but it
we have an incentive plan now
in this General Technologies
and it has a million dollars for the
Daily Journal stock that did not come
from the company issuing those shares I
gave those shares to the company to use
in compensating the employees
and I learned that trick so to speak
from a guy at byd which is one of the
Securities we hold in our Securities
portfolio
and byd at one time in its history the
founder chairman he didn't use the
company's stock to reward the executives
he used his own stock
it was a big reward too
well last year what happened byd last
year made more than two billion dollars
after taxes in the auto business in
China who in the hell makes two billion
dollars
it was a brand new internet
business for all practical purposes
it's incredible what's happened
and so there is some of this
old-fashioned capitalist virtue left in
the Daily Journal and there's something
left in Berkshire Hathaway and there's
some left at byd but but most places
everybody's trying to take what they
need and just rationalizing
whether it's deserved or not
Charlie you bring up byd so I'll jump to
a question from Stephen Spencer uh who
writes in from New York New York he's
curious why Mr Munger prefers an
investment in byd to Tesla
well that's easy
Tesla last year reduced its prices in
China twice byd increased its prices for
direct competitors
we're so much ahead of byad I mean byd
is so much ahead of Tesla and China it's
like a
it's just it's almost ridiculous
and
if you look at
byd which no mostly I've never heard of
if you count all the manufacturing space
they have in China to make cars it would
it would amount to a big percentage of
all the land in Manhattan Island
and nobody ever heard of them a few
years ago
all right let me jump to another
question this one comes from Michael
essayo who says did the this is regards
to some movement at Berkshire some sales
of Berkshire stakeholdings did the sale
of some byd and Taiwan semi shares have
anything to do with the relations
between the United States and China or
was it for purely economic reasons
well maybe when he's talking about 50
times earnings
that is a very high price on the other
hand they're likely to have increased
their auto sales by another 50 this year
so it's
we sold part of ours by the way years
ago
not years but about a year ago at a much
higher price than selling for now
and uh
no
we're not a mini Berkshire we're not
going to have a big correlation between
us and what Berkshire does
and
you you could understand why some people
will celebrate your byd stock at 50
times earnings
at the current price of byd stock
uh
uh little byd is worth more than the
entire Mercedes Corporation
hmm
market capitalization so it it's not a
cheap stock on the other hand
yeah
it's a very remarkable company and by
the way
I want to tell people the great
contribution I made to success because
success of byd
e i we got into it through lilu and
and there was a little company that
knocked off the Japanese cell phones
and
I think chairman who's got a genius say
I want to buy a bankrupt little crappy
Auto Plant
and I'm going to the auto business from
dead scratch when he's making cell
phones little tiny nothing governing and
both Lilo and I started talking about it
please don't do this dumb thing
if you get your head handed to you go
into the oil business little byd and so
forth
well last year they made more than two
billion dollars in the auto business
from that standing start at zero it's
unheard of but leilu at night is there
all the credit because we tried to get
them we tried to talk about them doing
what worked so well
which shows that there's some accident
in life
um Charlie this question comes from
Michael Gallagher he says according to
company filings it appeared that Alibaba
shares were purchased with leverage and
when the stock price fell last year he
was seemingly forced to sell he being
you can you ask Charlie to confirm that
it was bought with leverage and if so
why would he do that as it seems to go
against his philosophy I got several
questions that were similar to that
but yes that's it's true I
I operated with no leverage for long
stretches of my old age and Warren's the
same way and and recently I used a
little bit of Leverage here in another
place
because the opportunities were so
ridiculously good I thought it was
desirable to do that
so that you're right it's unusual for us
but we we did find a few things
and by the way if you go back early in
my career
I use some leverage I sometimes
ask myself a mental question I say
what is the appropriate percentage
of your net worth you should put it in
the stock if you think it's an absolute
sense
well if you're the kind of fellow who's
right and when you think something is a
cinch the answer is a hundred percent
or maybe 150 percent
but nobody in that nobody teaches people
to think that we're in finance
but but if the opportunity is great
enough The Logical answer is a hundred
percent
or maybe 200 percent
somebody else wrote in and I don't have
the email in front of me at the moment
but he wrote in um quoting you where he
said the three things that ruin people
are ladies liquor and leverage so why
would you use leverage when you know
that's one of the three things that can
destroy somebody
well I used a little under my way up and
so did Warren by the way the Buffett
partnership used Leverage
regularly every every year of its life
what Warren would do is he would buy a
bunch of stocks and then he'd borrow and
slow stocks need buy into these
uh they used to call it event Arbitrage
liquidations mergers and so forth
and that was not didn't go up and down
with the market that was like an
independent banking business and Ben
Graham's name for that that type of
investment he called them Jewish
treasury bills
and it always amused me that's what he
would call them
but born he was leveraged by Jewish
treasury bills when on the way up and it
worked fine for him
I don't think either of us everybody's
well no no
Berkshire has a stock in the Activision
Blizzard and you can argue that's
whether that'll go through or not I
don't know but but
that's the Jewish treasury bill
Arbitrage the Arbitrage play on
Activision well yes you Evander
Arbitrage are we but we we sort of
stopped doing it because it's such a
crowded place
but here's here's little Berkshire doing
it again an Activision Blizzard
and and Monger using a little leverage
as the Daily Journal Corporation
so is is leverage I use that leverage to
buy byd you can argue that's the best
thing I've ever done for the Daily
Journal so is is Leverage The the least
evil of the Three L's I think most
people should avoid it but maybe not
everybody need play by those rules I
have a friend who says the young man
knows the rules of the old man knows the
exceptions
all right another question he's lived
right he knows
another question comes in from uh
Brandon McKee he's also asking about
some of the situations with Alibaba he
said how should investors View
geopolitical events in regards to their
investment in foreign countries how do
you look at the situation of the recent
Chinese spy balloon in regards to the
Alibaba investment
well of course it was a very interesting
thing Jack ma was a dominant capitalist
in Alibaba
and one day he got up and made a public
speech where he basically said the
Communist party is full of Milwaukee
they don't know there has some terrible
they're no damn good and I'm smart
and of course
the Communist Party didn't particularly
like his speech
and pretty soon he just sort of
disappeared from view for months on end
and now he's out of byd
it was pretty stupid it's like poking a
bear in the nose with a sharp stick it's
not smart
and and Jack ma Got way
out of line by
popping off the way he did to the
Chinese government
and of course it hurt Alibaba and
but I regard alibaba's
one of the worst mistakes I ever made in
in
thinking about Alibaba I got Charmed
with the idea of their position on the
Chinese internet
I didn't stop to realize there's still a
goddamn retailer
it's it's going to be a competitive
business the Internet it's not going to
be a cakewalk for everybody
just about China in general I had a lot
of questions that came in regarding that
I'll ask this one from Wilco uh Wilco
shutzendorf it's coming in from Walnut
Creek California who just said
previously you stated that despite
certain shortcomings China was generally
moving in the right direction however
with the recent actions taken by the
Chinese government such as capriciously
punishing technology and educational
companies declining to import effective
covet vaccines escalating threats
towards Taiwan do you still maintain
that China is a viable investment option
for foreign capital or is China
experiencing a similar regression as
Russia has seen under Putin's leadership
that culminates in the invasion of
Taiwan
well that's a very good question of
course but
but I would argue that the chances in a
big conversation from China have gone
down not up because of what happened in
the Ukraine
I I think that the Chinese leader is
a very smart practical person
and it doesn't
Russia went into the Ukraine is a look
like a cakewalk
I don't think Taiwan looks like such a
cakewalk anymore I think it's off the
table and set on for a long long time
and I think that helps the prospects of
investors who invest in China and the
other thing that helps
in terms of the China prospects are that
you can buy the best
you can buy better stronger companies a
cheaper evaluation in China than you can
in the United States so you're getting
the extra risk can be worth running
given the extra value you get that's why
we're in China it's like we prefer being
in some foreign country
of course I'd rather be in Los Angeles
right next to my house you know it'll be
more convenient but I can't find that
many Investments you know right next to
my house
just to follow up on that um
Alex writes and Alex formanski I'm sorry
it's very small print writes in how have
political events in China over the last
few months affected your thinking on the
country several people including me were
taken aback by the forceful withdrawal
of former president hujin Tao at the
October 22 annual Congress president XI
seems to have Consolidated power and his
actions have indicated that he thinks
very differently about the role of
business in Chinese Society
well I I have more optimism about
the leader of the Chinese party than
most people do
he's done a lot right too
and
you know he would let a big
anti-corruption Drive he's done a lot of
things right so
and
I don't know where
this man lives
where is there a place where the
government is perfect in the world it's
so in sorrow
the democracies aren't that regularly
run either
so it's natural to have
some decisions made by government that
don't work well it's natural to have
decisions in each individual life that
don't work very well
we live in a world of sin sorrow and
misdecision that's that's what that
that's
what human beings get to cope with in
their days of life
so I I don't expect the world to be free
of
Folly in mistakes and so forth and I
just hope everything will have more
good judgments and bad judgment I don't
know anybody who's right all the time
and Keith from Cupertino California
writes in and this is in the same vein
but a little more focused how should we
think about the political political
climate around Taiwan and the long-term
impact on the semiconductor industry
specifically do you see the chips and
the science of the chips in science act
favorably
well
a semiconductor industry is a very
peculiar industry
and the semiconductor industry you have
to take all the money you've made
and and
with each new generation of chips you
throw in all the money you've previously
made
so it's compulsory reinvestment of
everything if you want to stay in the
game naturally I hate a business like
that
at Berkshire we like a whole lot of
surplus money to come in we can do
something else with and of course
now if you're enough ahead of it like
taiwan's semiconductor is
that that may be a good buy at these
prices I I I it's not at all clear to me
that
are going to succeed mightily but it's a
it's a difficult
it's a bit of an enormous promise for
the big winner but it's a difficult
business in requiring everybody to keep
increasing the bets on and on with all
the money and so
it's not perfect that semiconductor
business
but I remember when Intel on the world
intel was once the Taiwan semiconductor
business of the world yeah they invented
the damn business and they dominated it
for decades
and and until it's not clear to me that
it was Intel is going to have a very
decent semiconductor business getting as
far behind as they are now
it's my answer is it's not so damn
foolproof as it looked
even with the incentives to build plants
here in the United States it's like
Intel is doing in Ohio well of course
that will really help but they're
borrowing the money there's no
indication the government is going to
forgive the loans or something it's it's
not like the
recent loans to business where they said
well on your money then then it was
aware heck go keep the money
the government is not planning to do
that with these new semiconductor loans
and so
it's it's it's not a field where I feel
I have a lot of expertise what the hell
do I know about semiconductors
do you worry about any conditions that
the government would put on companies
that end up using any of that money with
semiconductors or anything else well of
course all of that it's deeply
intertwined with government policies of
both China
and the United States
so I would rather have something that's
more foolproof myself
but I do think Taiwan semiconductor is
the strongest selling conductor company
on Earth so I I'm a I'm a big admirer of
what they've achieved it's just
incredible of what they've achieved
speaking of things you like better and
by the way maybe a wonderful investment
the fact that I don't like it because
I'm an old man and I don't like learning
new tricks that doesn't mean it isn't
right for some younger person that
understands it better than I do okay
actually that's I'm gonna I'm gonna
switch gears we'll come back to this
question in a minute but that leads me
to this question about crypto that uh
Benjamin writes in he says in 2007 at
the USC Law School Charlie said I'm not
entitled to have an opinion on this
subject unless I can State the arguments
against my position better than the
people who are supporting it the
question is does this also apply to your
Wall Street Journal article on Banning
cryptocurrencies and if yes would you
care to share the arguments against your
position
well I I
don't think there are good arguments
against my position I think the people
will oppose my position are idiots
and
and so I don't think there is a rational
argument against my possession
this is an incredible thing naturally
people like to run gambling conceals
where other people lose
and the people who invented this
cryptocrapo which is my name for it
yeah sometimes I call it cryptocrabble
and sometimes I call it
you know crypto
and
it's just a ridiculous that anybody
would buy this stuff
yeah it isn't
you can think of hardly nothing on Earth
that's done more good to the human race
than currency National currencies
they were absolutely required to turn
man from a goddamn successful ape you
know about model modern successful
humans in human civilization
because it enabled all these convenient
exchanges so if somebody says I'm going
to create something that sort of
replaces the national currency
it's like saying I'm going to replace
the National Air you know it's it's
asinine
it is it isn't even slightly stupid it's
massively stupid
and and of course it's very dangerous
and of course the governments were
totally wrong to permit it and of course
I'm not proud of my country for allowing
this crap
what I call the crypto to it's
worthless it's no good it's crazy it'll
do nothing but harm it's anti-social to
allow it
and the guy who made the correct
decision on this is the Chinese leader
the Chinese leader took one look at
crypto and he says not in my China
boom Oh well
there isn't any crypto in China
he's right and we're wrong
and there is no good argument on the
other side I can't support it
so does that counter what you said back
at USC
that you shouldn't have a position
unless you can encounter I I do think
you ought to be able you ought to be
able to stay a lot of issues you ought
to be how big should the social safety
net be
that's a place where reasonable Minds
can disagree and you should be able to
state
the case on the other side about as well
so
in case you believe in
but when you're dealing with something
as awful as crypto
you're you uh
it's just unspeakable it's an absolute
horror and and I'm ashamed of my country
that so many people believe in this kind
of crap and the government allows it to
exist
it is totally absolutely crazy stupid
gambling with enormous house odds for
the people on the other side and they
cheat in addition to cheating in the
betting
you know it's just crazy
so that is something that there's only
one correct answer for intelligent
people there is just totally avoided
and avoid all the people that are
promoting it
how do you feel about the gambling that
took place at the Super Bowl and
surrounding that and the legalized
gambling taking place in this country at
this point well it's not as bad as
crypto
I I I I don't think there's much harm
in betting a modest amount you could
afford to own a supermarket bowl game
that that strikes me as pretty
you know if you do it with a friend and
not with a bookie and
so I I don't
I don't have the same feeling I I
obviously don't think you should have a
gambling compulsing door around begging
against odds if you take all the money
that I have bet against odds in my whole
life I don't think it's more than a few
thousand dollars
Alan Shea writes in and he says first
I'm all in favor everybody with the odds
with the odds yeah
Alan Shay writes no sure he says if Mr
Munger thinks that Bitcoin and ethereum
are rat poison has he ever profited by
shorting them
no I don't short
I that isn't great I have made three
short sales in my entire life and
they're all more than 30 years ago
and
and and one was a currency and and there
were two stock trades in the two stock
trades
I'm I made a big profit on one of them
made a big loss on the other and they
canceled out
and I and my currency bet I made a
million dollars but it was a very
irritating way to make a million dollars
I I I've stopped
not worth the headache I guess well you
can laugh but that but that's that's
true it was irritating
because you were worried
well because I kept asking if her more
margin
I kept sending over treasury notes
it was very unpleasant
I made a profit in the end but I never
wanted to do it again
Charlie I said I'd come back to this
question this was about something that
you do like as an investment Ami Patel
from Montreal Quebec writes in that you
love Costco so what do you think can
hurt Costco's economic mode in the long
term
well
as long as Costco keeps the faith the
strong culture
and their extreme low markup policy
I don't see any stopping it
the trouble with Costco is it's 40 times
earnings
but but except for that it's a perfect
damn comedy
and it has a marvelous future
and it has a wonderful culture and it's
been run by wonderful people and I I I I
love everything about Costco I'm a total
addict
and I'm never going to sell a share
all right the next question comes from
David Cass who's a professor of Finance
at the University of Maryland he says
he's a shareholder of the Daily Journal
Corporation and would appreciate it if
you'd answer one of these questions
um the question that I met that I'll ask
from is it is President Biden has
proposed increasing the tax on stock
BuyBacks from its current level of one
percent to a new higher level of four
percent what are your views on taxing
stock BuyBacks
well I'm strongly opposed because
I think if you're
you're a good culture
has a lot of people that are good
fiduciaries
and
it is
like stealing to do something dumb with
the corporate money when it's you can
get more advantage to your show or so
buy back your own stock
and I like encouraging morality and
decency and honor and so on your
dealings with the people you're the
fiduciary for
and so
I agree with our president on some
things but this is not one of them
they immensely disagree
well well vehemently disagree say it
again do you vehemently disagree
well I'm not vehement because
it's not as bad as cryptocurrency
yeah
it's a forgivable error but yes I I
disagree
strongly I think it's a big mistake to
to adopt that policy but you know I'm a
republican I I sometimes vote for
Democrats but I am a Republican
another question on stock BuyBacks comes
in from Ed prendeville in Morristown New
Jersey he says Berkshire share
repurchases slowed considerably from
three billion dollars in the first
quarter of 2022 to a billion dollars in
the second quarter and a billion dollars
in the third quarter even though the
price declined somewhat as did the
General market one would think that the
buyback would increase with a lower
stock price does Berkshire adjust its
buyback price based on the intrinsic
value of the approximately 300 billion
dollar stock portfolio or the quoted
price
I never pay any attention to how they do
it
they they're they're cautious and
careful people
and I but if you take the amount that's
been bought back in the last three years
it's a lot and I thoroughly approve what
we're doing and I don't consider it all
fair that we're being taxed because we
are doing something good for our own
shareholders
the president laid out the case today I
think he said something like north of 90
percent of executives are paid with
stock compensation at least in part he
said maybe this was yesterday that he
said this he said that that's not fair
the best way to Goose your own
compensation is to buy back your share
so it helps the executives it helps the
share the shareholders but it doesn't
help the employees or other constituents
well there's no question about the fact
that he sympathizes with the employees
more and that's understandable
and a lot a lot of people would have the
president's orientation on that issue
and
I I I I don't have a big opinion about
how well thought to be distributed in
the country I think
I don't know the answer
I do think we need a capitalistic system
if we want to have a productive economy
to make civilization advance
all right the next question comes in
from Michael and I think his last name
is maso but I'm going based on the
address from the email and not a given
last name he says he's a very long time
Berkshire share owner that who read an
irritating recent Barons article that
stated Berkshire shareholders could
benefit after Warren as the company
could come under pressure to break up I
don't see how we would benefit with our
businesses being broken up as you and
Warren have long stayed at the company
as a whole is stronger than and one
division could always Aid another
division in need
he says he knows Warren and and you
Charlie have said that the current
structure and philosophies will be
preserved after your departures and I
hope for a very I hope not for a very
long time however please offer us share
owners reassurance that the company
would never succumb to these silly
pressures to break it up
well I don't think it's at all likely
it'll be broken up for a long long time
a lot of companies are worth more debt
than alive meaning at the current price
for whole businesses you could sell
things at higher prices but you can only
do it once the Sherwood is a very big
tax then you'd have the problem what to
do with the money and so forth
I think all factors considered and with
Berkshire buying in its own shares when
they're reasonably priced
I think berkshire's a pretty damn good
bet for Charlotte as a whole at long
term in the future and I don't think
it's any hardship but it isn't being
broken up
it works pretty damn well
everybody that bought Berkshire held on
for 20 years has done well
I think that will be true for those who
buy it at the current price
what about the potential for pressure I
don't think it'll be as good in the
future as it was in the past but it will
be okay considering how poorly
everything else is going to do
why do you think everything else is
going to do so poorly
because the valuations start higher now
and because government is so hostile to
business
and that's a view over the next 5 10 20
years how far out are you thinking
I I would say it'll fluctuate naturally
between administrations and so on but
but but I think basically the culture of
the world will become more and more
anti-business in the big democracies
and I think taxes will go up not down
so I think the investment world is going
to get harder for everybody
and but it's been almost too easy in the
past for the investment class
it's natural it would have a period of
getting harder
Mike I don't worry about it much because
I'm going to be dead
you know it won't bother me very much
when I'm lost like they're dead
I guess you want to point out to people
you're 99 nobody lives forever and
that's what you're referring to you're
not sick I know 99 right you're not sick
at the moment right
well no I'm eating this good peanut
brittle that's what you want to do if
you want to live to be 99.
we did get some people who wrote in
asking I hate to advertise my own
product but this is the key to longevity
she's peanut brittle I can see I saw the
Box earlier we did get a lot of people
who wrote in questions just asking what
your daily habits are
um what what you do every day if you
exercise if you think exercising a lot
when you're younger is important to
longevity
well that's a very I have
almost no exercise except when the Army
Air corps made me do exercise I've done
almost no exercise on purpose in my life
if I enjoyed the activity like tennis I
would exercise
but
for the first 99 years I've gotten by
without doing any exercise at all
and you're not planning on changing that
anytime soon
no no I I'm not changing it
other people's mileage may vary yeah
looking for one question that somebody
wrote in because I I want to word it
properly and it has to do with what
you've just been talking about
I don't know if I can find it there's a
lot of questions in here uh
oh here it is somebody said this came
from adidi Gone in Australia what would
the 100th day of your life look like and
how would you want to spend it when you
step out of bed in the morning
foreign
I step out of my bed these days and say
again sit down in my wheelchair so I am
paying some price for old age
but I prefer it to being dead and and
whenever I feel sad maybe in a
wheelchair I think well you know
Roosevelt ran the whole damn country for
12 years in a wheelchair
so
I'm just trying to make this filter
thing last as long as Roosevelt did
that's a good plan I like it
um somebody else wrote in this is Adam
Mead and he said Charlie in your 1995
talk the psychology of misjudgment you
listed senescence as a cause of
misjudgment you said old people like me
get pretty skilled without working on it
at disguising age-related deterioration
because social convention like clothing
hides much decline you went on to say
that such decline was inevitable he says
you're my hero Charlie and I offer you
this question with the utmost respect
but feel it needs to be asked would 71
year old Charlie just trust the judgment
and mental capacity of 99 year old
Charlie
well there's no question about the fact
that you lose some mental acuity as you
get older but some people get Schroeder
at
adapting to their limitations and they
do pretty well and
so far I
I've had plenty of decline but I'm
pretty shrewd about the way I handle it
and so far the results have not been
that bad in my old age
would be a different subject
laughs
well I I will point out to people we
have not given you any of these
questions in advance so you're taking
blind questions
um yeah that's all right yeah for a
large stretch of time on this too
uh
okay how do I follow that up this one's
another question this gets back to
investing what we were just talking
about a minute ago but Michael worked
early writes in and says given the
increasing rate environment what are the
ramifications of moving away from a
close to zero interest rate policy
Warren and yourself a frequently spoken
about Aesop and a bird in the hand is
worth two in the bush to describe the
essence of investment decision making so
what do you do now that the interest
rate environment is changing
well there's no question about the fact
that as the interest rates have gone
up it's
it's hostile to stock prices so and but
they should go up we couldn't have kept
them forever at zero
and
I just think this is one more damn thing
to adapt to an investment life is that
there are
there are headwinds and there are
Tailwinds and one of the headwinds is
inflation
and I think more inflation over the next
100 years is inevitable with given the
nature of democratic politics
politics in a democracy so I think we'll
have more inflation that's one of the
reasons The Daily Journal owns
Securities instead of government bonds
Owens Common Stocks instead of
government bonds
when you say the nature of democratic
policies and I forget exactly how you
worded it are you talking about the
Democratic party are you talking about
democracy
wait listen to that Trump ran a deficit
that was bigger than the Democrats did
yeah
all Democratic all politicians in a
democracy tend to
be in favor of printing the money and
spending it
and that will cause some inflation over
time
it may avoid a few recessions too it may
not be all bad but it will do more harm
than good I think from this point
forward
okay on that point Ron
uh
tree rotola Ron tree rotola says should
we may continue to maintain a debt limit
the adjustment process seems to be a
very simple and mechanical process
however such a measure only seems to
create an environment Rife with
political jocking and sniping what's the
purpose if we continue to budget beyond
our means and then the bill comes due
well
if you take the history of democracy in
the world
and go back far enough it fails a lot
and gets succeeded by dictatorships and
all kinds of awful things
and as a matter of fact the worst thing
that happened to the human race in my
lifetime was of an advanced civilization
like Germany was taken over by a
dictator as awful Los adol Hitler
that happened as a consequence of a big
worldwide depression
it would never have happened if we
hadn't had the big depression
and once Hitler got in and that meant we
were World War II was inevitable and
that could have worked out a lot worse
than it did for the people like the
United States
so the these things are quite important
and
and they're not going to be done
perfectly in the future no more than
they were done perfectly in the past
so so of course you've got to expect a
certain amount of future trouble in the
world and your government's going to do
some things that aren't exactly right
on the other hand I would argue that the
U.S government did some things
magnificently right I have said on many
an occasion that if the thing that makes
me proudest of my own government is the
way we handled the sequel to World War
II
instead of punishing the Germans and the
Japanese
we made them into some of our best
friends on earth now that was a stunt
and it was to the credit of our country
that that was done and it was done on a
bipartisan basis
and I think we can all be proud of that
that was a smart thing to do it took
some generosity we had to give up some
of our money to help them rebuild
and it was it was a credit to our
species that we behaved that well on
that occasion and I don't think our
future Behavior will lack similar
episodes of some kind
black similar episodes something's very
right and something's very wrong that's
our that's the way it happens yeah
that's very churchless right they'll try
everything all the wrong wrong things
until we do the right thing
no I will I will keep doing both wrong
and right as far ahead as you can see
um
Charlie Al pitten writes in from Chicago
and wants to know if you think we might
have on and off waves of inflation like
we did prior to when volcker stepped in
at the Fed
the 70s era of course it will happen
some in the future yes I think we'll
have some of that in the future do you
think we'll have it immediately right
now with what the Jay pal is dealing
with I don't I don't I don't I I don't
regard myself
I think I'm pretty good at long run
expectations but I don't think I'm going
to
short-term wobbles
I don't know the famous idea is what's
going to happen short term okay
well let me ask this one as a follow-up
it's it's similar and you may not want
to answer this one either but Jake
pillard says do you have faith in Jay
Powell are you expecting us off Landing
well tell you the way I feel about Jay
Paul
is that I feel he's about as good as we
have any right to expect
I think he's honorable and intelligent
and doing the best he can and I have no
feeling that I know a lot of people who
do it a lot better
so wow so I'm glad we have him
Charlie another question comes in from
Chris freed of Philadelphia Pennsylvania
he says you've recommended the use of an
index fund for the average investor as
these index funds continue to expand in
size their influence on corporate boards
and ultimately management is ever
increasing this concentration of voting
in the hands of a few index funds is
alarming to me do you see this
concentration as alarming as well and
what reforms would you suggest to
address that issue
well of course it's a very serious issue
because it's enormous amount of power
and for a while all these index funds
got the feeling they were
suddenly made god-like to
clean up the world
and but Vanguard has retreated from that
policy
and I think wisely so
and I have some hope that Larry Fink
will follow
I I don't think it's smart for for these
index funds to try and influence the
policy and politics of the country just
because they're an index fund I think
they
should be satisfied to eliminate some of
the following from investment management
and do a better job for their clients
which I think they do very well
and I think they should be pleased with
that and not try and run the whole damn
country as a matter of corporate
governance I have no feeling that
anybody at Vanguard or
or
Larry thinks operation has any special
Genius of how American corporations
ought to be run
extent they asked Berkshire to do this
or that I wish they'd stop
ask bersha to do what to oh to follow
their their guidance I'm just not
interested in their views as to how
Berkshire should behave
all right this next question comes from
Carson federoff who's an equity allynist
analyst from German Germany and his
question is stock based compensation is
a popular means of incentive
compensation in many companies in some
cases these take on alarming proportions
it feels like companies are competing to
outbid each other in some companies 20
of sales are paid out in stock based
compensation how do you perceive this
development in recent years and what's a
heavy what's a healthy level of
incentives
well I think you will find in American
corporations very good incentive systems
and others that are too liberal and
others that are too naggardly
and what else would you expect of human
nature but a certain amount of variety
and
I agree that some of this
in many a corporation
everybody would vote to being allowed to
have stock-based compensation you didn't
count it in Computing the earnings
they just want any damn way of making
the earnings appear higher it's just
human nature of course they want their
it's like your little kid goes off to
school they want a very own good grades
not bad grades
and
and so it's it's sure there's a big
problem of excess Corporation
pay in some places
other places like Costco
I would say the compensation system is
damn near perfect
it's it's
uh and and there's a fair amount of
stock but we always buy in enough stock
in Costco to pay for the stock we're
issuing a lot of people in high tech
they issue the stock
and they and they they don't look they
don't buy it in so it's in that delusion
I think there's a lot that's wrong in
American compensation systems and
but
why wouldn't there be
by the way when I was young it wasn't so
bad
why this is something that's happened in
the last 50 years
I don't know it's just the history of
the way things came up and the greater
hardship and the pioneering ethos or God
whatever it was
when I was young executive nobody
complained about executive compensation
now practically everybody in the
investment world thinks in many cases
the executive compensation has gotten
too high
take General Electric in its Heyday
think of all the big compensation
packages
they paid and think of how they were
phoning up the earnings and so forth to
pay for it
it was disgusting
and and of course if that kind of crap
Creeps in everywhere in our civilization
the civilization will perish
we need more honor not less
and
but I haven't any I have no suggestion
as to how to
fix the places where it's excessive
it's a difficult issue really difficult
Jeffrey Malloy writes in and and asks
this question uh he's from San Francisco
he says do you think Elon musk's
ownership of Twitter specifically his
hands-off approach to content moderation
is good or bad for American society
well you know I don't use Twitter
so I'm not a good judge on that subject
and my policy and Elon Musk is that he's
a very talented man but also peculiar
and so I
I don't buy him and I don't sell them
short
I just say well he's a very unusual
person
you said some nice things about him the
last time I talked to you and what he's
done with Tesla
oh it's unbelievable
who else is a donut except byd
it just shows how tough capitalism is
even if you're a genius like musk is in
some ways
there's always some little byd that
comes out and does better
capitalism is not easy
all right this question came in from
Jeremy Salzburg in Costa Mesa California
he says Charlie last year in 2022 a
Missouri court awarded a victim 5.2
million dollars in compensation from
Berkshire subsidiary Geico after a woman
was infected with an STD in a car that
was insured by Geico auto insurance the
claimant says that the man was negligent
and didn't tell her about his health
diagnosis your grandfather was a judge
and you have a background in law did the
Missouri court get this verdict right
well I wouldn't doubt it myself but but
it's in the nature of things that not
every court is going to be right in
every verdict for every judgment
and
I do think that allowing
that you again you're raised a very
tough subject
you you will get an occasional verdicts
that are just totally outrageous
and and that's inevitable and of course
that's what appellate courts are for but
sometimes the Abella courts are very
sympathetic with
with crazy verdicts
again I can't fix everything that's
wrong with you in life and I including a
few crazy verdicts
you'd put that in the category of a
crazy verdict though
yeah sure
this question comes from Stefan Armand
who is writing in from Toronto there was
a lot of excitement about the
relationship between Berkshire and 3G
for the Kraft Heinz transaction has your
perception of the private Equity
business changed on the back of that
partnership
well
like every other human being on Earth
some deals
work out better than others for 3G
and
they would love to have a way of going
back and turning all their bad deals
into good deals Berkshire would like to
have the same option if we don't get it
either
averaged out through 3G did pretty well
but
recently there they've had some
their approach hasn't worked as well
in recent years has it as would be ideal
again welcome to human life it isn't so
damned easy
art presser writes in and says the
Florida governor and legislative body
has recently taken a stand to try and
control Disney's exclusive
self-governing Authority
previously set up in Florida under the
founder Walt Disney as your organization
I guess by this they mean DJ Co still
owns Disney shares you think Disney
Shares are still a good investment given
this backdrop
we've never on Disney's years
that's my mistake though
no but
Disney is an interesting case
practically every business that Disney
has has gotten tougher than it used to
be
again welcome to human life
think about Disney once owned the world
Lion King was running the long run on
met on the Theater District of New York
they went from triumphs around marching
marching marching
all of a sudden I'm practically every
front it's more difficult
this is what happens
imagine Kodak which totally dominated
Photography in the world
and the invented this new technology
Kodak wiped out its comment shareholders
you think Disney's headed down the same
path or you think that they'll be able
to Pivot I mean I know you followed the
company no I think Disney has a lot of
Assets in it but yeah
it's unpleasant to have something how
would you like running the sports
ESPN now at Disney compared to it's a
day
it's going to be way harder for them
movies movies look to me like it's going
to be a bloodbath too so it's not a bit
easy
and it was easy in the Heyday of ESPN
Disney made nothing but money out of
ESPN
the total gold mine
what about other uh
movie businesses I I'm thinking of
Paramount which is a huge holding that
Berkshire now owns recent
is I live within a few blocks of
Paramount Studios
and
I don't even know anybody at Paramount
I have avoided the movies like the
plague as an investor all my life
I've never made an investment in a movie
business in any way shape better or form
it always gives me the will it was I
don't like the unions
I don't like the crazy agents I don't
like the goddamn crazy lawyers I don't
like the crazy movie stars I don't like
the people who sell dope to them
musicians I mean everything about it is
not my culture I like those old English
actors when they came over
you know
I grew up with them
and but basically
movies is not my scene so I I've avoided
it
it's a very it's always been very hard
for the people who put up the money
it may be a very good place to make a
living as an actor or a writer or
something or a musician but it's a hard
place to make money if you're an
investor
one's an interesting question I came in
from Eric Howe in Milwaukee who says the
population of the world is thought to
have increased by more than four-fold
time
since you were born mind you I'm not
holding you personally responsible but
there has been that magnitude of growth
is there a point where the biggest
existential threat to humanity is the
growth of the population and Humanity if
so
how do we discern when that point has
arrived
well that's an interesting subject if
you'd looked at the
way things that happened in the past you
would have concluded like Paul there
like did that the world's headed for an
absolute population disaster
but what actually has happened is quite
different
what's happened is that as the world has
gotten more and more prosperous
including in places like China the birth
rate has gone down down down down
and so that
there's actually sort of a population
shortage in a place like Japan
so the production of all the great
experts based on extrapolating the past
graphs it turned out to be totally wrong
it now looks as early
world's population in the advanced
countries will sort of self-limited
I mean that that kind of puts you in the
same camp with Elon Musk he's made some
of the same arguments that it's really
shrinking population that's a bigger
threat to humanity
now as I said he's a smart man
sometimes
sometimes like all the rest of us
Denny Poland writes in and says when
assessing the character and competence
of a business's management have you ever
made a mistake if so when did this occur
and what did you learn from the
experience
well everybody makes mistakes
I am
one of the
I'd say one of the most interesting
things that happened in my lifetime
was the rise of IBM
and the fall of IBM
IBM was the most admired company in
America for most of my young life
they just marched from triumphs to
Triumph of the triumph
and you know in the last 10 or 15 years
they've slipped and they've they're
they're falling back in relation to
other people in their field
that's the
apples and the
Googles and so forth came ahead IBM just
they kind of missed the boat
I think that's almost inevitable
Kodak missed the boat of the changed
digital photography too
and
I've heard Bill Gates say that it's
almost the rule and a really disruptive
technology comes along the incumbents
screw up their reaction to it
it's hard to change your ways when
they've been successful for a long time
and go into a totally different way of
behaving
[Applause]
and thinking
right this question is where we're
sitting we're seeing in Daily Journal
Corporation
we're adapting to the new world see how
different it is publishing a newspaper
and and being a
inventing software records to automate
these are two radically different
businesses
this question comes in from someone
named Gene who says Mr Munger do you
think that currently in the United
States we have systemic racism
we have what systemic racism
well I suppose we've got some sure
of course you're going to have a certain
amount of animosity one group toward
another and the whole history of the
human race we've had a certain amount of
that
I think it's gotten way better in my
lifetime however
I would argue that the racism is going
down
a lot
foreign
Charlie this question comes in from Neil
Doss who says what if any impact do you
think the insurance industry will see
because of climate change over the next
25 years
well I'm not sure I hear any good
answering that kind of a question
are you raising rates at any of the
Berkshire insurance I don't think I
don't think I I don't think I know
particularly I will
I think there's a good chance that
climate change
will be less important than a lot of
people think
that doesn't mean it'll be unimportant
but I think it won't be an absolute
for one horror capacity with no
possibility into a just
oh I wait because sometimes when I wait
you say more on things
but I'll give you time to no it's all
right okay uh let me get to this
question from Tony Huang He says that
he's teaching the introduction of
personal finance and the introduction of
corporate finance to undergraduates at
Indiana University in Bloomington most
of his students are non-finance majors
and this will likely be the only finance
class that they take in college what
should he teach them incorporating as
many writings and speeches that you've
given over the years so that they have
the foundations and common sense to
effectively deal with their personal or
corporate finance problems later in life
well it's that's a good question because
it's a big question
and
if you have good judgment your life will
work a lot better than if you have bad
judgment
and you get good judgment gradually over
time partly they're making bad judgments
and having them work out poorly and
so my
counsel has always been to start trying
to be better and keep doing
keep trying to improve all your life and
you've got about half a chance
if you don't do that you've got like no
chance
and so
I I
it's
I I used to say I could only teach with
the other person almost knows then I can
just chew him over the brink when he's
hanging on the edge but if the guy is
not within miles of even starting I
never make any any public I never
succeed
so in removing idiocy I I have no I have
a 100 fail and you tell
[Music]
I've never succeeded
what would you push in that direction if
you've got a class full of Finance
students in college maybe one of the a
few questions I would teach to the
people who can learn and that the others
couldn't keep up the hell with them
Well it can't be improved can't be
approved I just I don't believe in
putting my head against the wall
and that by the way that's the way most
Education Works they just throw out
those who can't give up that's the way
Academia works that's the reason it gets
so good at the top
I talked yesterday on Zoom with a law
professor at a great place
oh my God this is an admirable guy and
he's just so goddamn smart and balanced
incredible but he's a very senior law
teacher one of the great law schools of
the world
so I would expect them to be pretty good
but he was more than pretty good he was
awesome
and I thought my God Academia is quite
competitive you know by the time you get
to the top of
the professors at a good place you find
some very remarkable people
and
but what they but
they can't
there's a limit to what they can
accomplish
one of the reasons they turn out such
good people is they take in such good
people that's their secret
they can't fix the clods
nobody can
tough love there's an old saying dumb is
for dumbest forever
dumb and diamonds uh
Alejandro Salcedo writes in he says
reading many entrepreneurs and famous
people they always say that you have to
dream really big instead you say Charlie
that the secret to a happy life is
having low expectations could you please
expand on that
well yes and you climb as hard as you
can by just advancing one inch at a time
that's the secret of life
and now there's always somebody who's a
little nuts and who succeeds but that's
but for every guy who's exceeds there
are a thousand failures
is this an under promise over to over
deliver situation too
well of course
who in the hell in his right mind
would like going around making a lot of
commitments and failing Time After Time
After Time and doing what you'd promise
to do
everybody would hate you right there's
no more guaranteed way to make people
hate you than to fail them in their
reasonable expectations
so
of course you want to live a life where
by and large you're meeting the
reasonable expectations of other people
that's what civilization requires of all
of us
Charlie someone named Joe Rhoden from
China and he says he's an investor from
China he's sorry that he can't see you
face to face this year he wants to ask
you a question about life during the
pandemic he says I always give bits of
advice to the elders in my family like
avoiding high temperatures and falling
down at home but during the pandemic
especially since China reopened I can
seldom give them any advice except stay
at home and get vaccinated so as a wise
Elder yourself did you get coveted
during the pandemic and how do you stay
healthy what's your advice to these
elders
I did get covered but I got it after I
was vaccinated and I had like a tiny
sniffle for about 10 minutes
and that was my covert but I tested
positive during that time
and
and in terms of of
the general idea of cautious adjustment
I had so a lot of elderly friends who
either died or had terrible injuries
from Falls
and so when I got old myself
and it got time
to
use something to avoid falling down
people tried to sell me on the cane
but I noticed that my friends who use
canes would fall down occasionally
so I did I never used the goddamn cane
instead I bought one of these modern
Walkers and wherever I was worried about
falling down I pushed my Walker I did
that for six and a half years I never
fell down once in six and a half years
just because I was more cautious that is
my advice to old people just be a little
more cautious
now I've gone to the wheelchair
and
I've got another six and a half yards
probably
but some of it I've already used up and
and
I'm just as cautious of my wheelchair
what is the harm of having a little
extra caution
makes sense
I want to Pivot to a question from Frank
Wang in Houston Texas uh this question
about Berkshire he said Berkshire
previously took a position in Exxon and
then exited fairly quickly if I recall
correctly he says I believe you had
stated that Berkshire thought it was a
good alternative to cash at the time is
the same type of thinking with
berkshire's new position and Occidental
and Chevron is it the same type of
thinking or is it likely to be more of a
long-term type of holding for Berkshire
going forward
well that is a very good question
and
I think having a big position
in the Permian Basin
through those two companies is likely to
be a pretty pretty good long-term hold
so I like that aspect of that position
and Ben Graham used to say if it's a
good investment it may be a good
speculation
and I think that's generally true but I
don't do those short-term speculations
at least not very often
and but I but I like the big position
that that
Berkshire has in the Permian through
those two I kind of admire both places a
lot both Occidental and Chevron are very
admirable places
and
by the way oxy didn't start like that
yeah if you go back 30 or 40 years Aki
was owned by a crook and you know it
it's a
it's evolved into a wonderful place but
it started as a sleaze bag
who was running it 30 or 40 years ago
a man named Armand Hammer oh
before your time Becky you're too young
I know Armie Hammer the
younger one
yeah yeah
anyway
uh all right uh Paul D writes in and I
believe it's
Paul damikoff says Charlie you're
largely credited with Warren Buffett's
Evolution to buying great businesses at
a reasonable price or in simple terms a
willingness to pay up for a great
business given Ben Graham's exceptional
insights and understanding of investing
how or why did he himself not evolve to
foresee the inability to scale his net
net cigar butt approach what do you
attribute your early willingness to pay
up stems from
remember a lot of Ben Graham's rise in
life
was during a period when there was
plenty of low-hanging fruit among
mediocre businesses that were way too
cheap
and he was relatively rare and
in doing his hunting in that Garden
and so he made a pretty good living for
himself buying these
and what happened is that that
low-hanging fruit eventually went away
as the after half of the Great
Depression went away
and Ben Graham actually made more than
half of all the money he made in his
life out of one stock
and that stock was Geico which was a
great business
so
if you actually look at the great man's
own life you see that
what he taught
wasn't the way he got rich himself
and by the way he told that story on
himself late in life
he carefully computed how much he'd made
in Geico compared to everything he had
ever done in his previous life
and
so
you can argue that Ben Graham himself
woke up once
what uh why do you think that you so
early on were willing to to come up with
this idea of paying up for for great
businesses
well because it's so obvious and I'm
good at doing things that are obvious
of course it was obvious if you wanted
to have particularly good result you got
into a great company you know I I
recognize that greatness was good you
know
big deal Charlie Munger genius
recognizes greatness as good
this greatness is good
Paul aini from Toronto Canada writes and
he says when you're evaluating a company
for potential investment what do you
place the most emphasis on the business
or the management and do you differ with
Warren when it comes to what you place
first
no I know I think we're the same I think
we like the business great first
and then second we want a great manager
but we
we have not made a huge success by
investing on grade managers to take over
lousy businesses that is not the way we
Rose
Matt McAllister writes you're a lousy
manager you really you really need a
great business
and can a great business be run by a
lousy manager the inverse
so sometimes Coca-Cola was run for years
by a man with a very severe mental
impairment
and the director just assumed he was
drunk and let him stay there year after
year
now that's my idea of a wonderful
business that you
you can be mentally defective and rather
pretty well that was Coca-Cola and it's
a day
how far back were we talking
oh well 25 years
foreign
do the math on that figure out the
timing Matt McAllister writes in and
says Charlie you've described too much
diversification as diversification being
at best an average return producing
strategy in light of that thought if one
was allowed only one stock to hold for a
very long time and it would be the most
important asset to him and his family
and their future well-being please
describe what you would look for in that
stock or company and also talk about the
features that you would consider most
important when you're trying to to
figure that out
well it helps to have a somebody that
said lucked into a good position
so a great business it'll be what you'd
like and of course you'd like a great
management too and occasionally we've
had both the right together for a long
long period
and
but of course everybody's looking for
the same thing
and the trouble with it is you will find
when you get into those good businesses
that place is picked over and
analyzed as American stocks are you can
imagine the amount of time spent
thinking about American stocks
and
you will find by and large in America
it's really a great business it's at
least 25 times earnings and maybe 30 or
35 or something
so that makes it a much harder of course
because if something goes wrong you can
lose a lot of your investment
and and of course that's what makes
investment so difficult is the fact that
the good business
the good businesses don't stay cheap you
gotta somehow recognize a good business
before it's recognizable as a good
business that's very hard to do some
people get good at it but not many
I don't think I would want
95 of the people who are America's
professional asset managers I wouldn't
want working for me
really I think it's that hard
I think you need to be in the top five
or so
they have a reasonable chance it's it's
very difficult
now it's not difficult this is by an
index feeling sitting on your ass that
that's the great default position your
assets
and by the way that's that's if you said
look at the Daily Journal Corporation we
just put in a 401K plan
what are the investment options for the
people that work zero
it's all index funds
what percentage of American what
percentage of American 401ks have our
plan
index funds required
about zero
am I right or am I wrong of course I'm
right
that's a logical thing to do okay so
percent worth two and twenty
uh sometimes
sometimes
being worth 2 and 20 I I would say
that is way less than five percent
the van is worth two and twenty that is
really that's getting that's getting
very rare indeed
particularly under modern conditions
where every Niche is occupied
it's you you really
if you take
early stage Venture Capital likes La
Jolla does
how many people have a sequoia-like
record
I don't think there's one in
a hundred thousand square trap record
Chris Reed from Philadelphia
Pennsylvania writes in and says you've
said previously that and by the way even
Sequoia makes even Sequoia makes an
occasional mistake they you know
everybody does
yeah
but overall you still think it's worth
it yeah okay so Chris freed writes in
from Philadelphia and says you've
previously you've said previously that
you should destroy at least one uh good
idea that you have each year what good
idea did you destroy in 2022 and
anything in 2023 so far
well the idea that I destroyed it was it
wasn't a good idea it was a bad idea
when the internet came in
I got over Charmed by the people who
were leading in the online retailing
and I didn't realize it's still
retailing you know it may be online
retailing but it's also still retailing
and I just I got a little out of focus
and that made me overestimate the future
returns from Alibaba and
and so
I have never gotten twice about lemonade
mistakes and I think I just lost
Charlie's audio
rubbing my own nose in my own mistakes
like I am doing now because I think it's
good for myself
I can hear me but I can't hear you you
dropped out during that last question
can you do me a favor just raise your
hand if you can hear me
um Charlie can hear me I I'm not hearing
him so if you guys can call and I'm
hooked in directly to the line
now I'm hearing program
not this program I'm hearing live on air
program coming from here music that's
coming in Charlie I'm going to ask you
another question just so that everybody
else doesn't have to listen to the to me
talking this through we're going to try
and get this fixed here in the control
room but this question comes in from
let's see let's go to this one Chris
Benassi who asked the question about he
says hi Charlie a notable theme during
the last Daily Journal conversation
revolved around positive and negative
trade-offs between different systems
Frameworks and choices can you discuss
your views on the health care industry
specifically the trade-offs between
capitalist systems like the United
States and single-payer systems like
Canada in in the UK and I'm asking this
single-payer Health Care question
because for those who don't know you
serve for a long time Mr chairman at a
hospital in Los Angeles so you do have
some insights into what this situation
is and feel free to talk a long time
while they're fixing this
but yes all right and
I don't hear anything when somebody
asked Warren what happened when their
experiment with JP Morgan Chase and
Amazon and so forth
and they were going to change
they
improve the the
what was wrong with the American
medicine and its cost and
and when they gave that up as a total
failure
Warren just said the tapeworm won
and that's what happens I'm the American
system is
costs way too much
can you hear me
Charlie I see your lips have stopped
moving
so I'm going to ask another question
yeah I'm hearing power lunch in my ear
right now if anybody's paying attention
in the control room
um but this question comes in
from Brad heck Brad heck is in South St
Paul Minnesota and says Charlie I'm a
big fan of your disciplined approach to
life do you get up at the same time
every day and go to the bed at the same
time and finally what's the first thing
you focus on each day
well I vary a little in my time but I'm
pretty regular
and I'm a pretty good sleeper in my old
age so I'm very lucky in that respect
and
see your lips have stopped moving so
much got you I got you ah finally I hear
you okay Charlie let me ask you this
question you got sound again yeah I've
got you modern technology yeah yeah I
know we think we'd be a little better at
this sometimes it works uh Jim Noel
writes in and said if you could
inaugurate anyone for president in 2024
who would you choose
well I think I'll duck that one
I don't want to get into presidential
politics
okay I hear that I can understand that
uh
Charles writes in and says first of all
he wants to thank you Charlie for
gifting some DJ co-shares to establish
that newly that new Daily Journal
management Equity incentive plan you
talked about that earlier on he said
additionally he's excited about the
rumored new addition of poor Charlie's
Almanac first of all is that true but
the real question he has for you he said
you said that you admire Benjamin
Franklin can you please elaborate on
this subject and highlight the qualities
that you admire in Ben Franklin
well Ben Franklin
was a genius
if you it was a small country but
remember he started in absolute poverty
his father made soap out of the
carcasses of dead animals that stank
now that is a very low place to start
from
and he was almost entirely self-educated
two or three years of primary school and
after that he had to learn all himself
well the rise from that
kind of a starting position
and become by the time he died he was
the best inventor in his country the
best scientist in his country the best
writer in this country the best Diplomat
in this country
you know thing after thing after thing
he was the best there was in the whole
United States so he was a very unusual
person
and
he just got an extremely high IQ and a
very kind of pithy way of talking that
made him
very useful to his fellow citizens and
he kept inventing all these things a man
imagine inventing the Franklin stove and
bifocal classes and all these things
that we use all the time
I'm wearing bifocal glasses as I'm
looking at you
these are Ben Franklin glasses what the
hell kind of a man that just goes
through life and his sight gets a little
perfect
he advanted the goddamn bifocals
and it was just one of his many
inventions
so he was a very very remarkable person
and
of course I admire somebody like that
we don't get very many people like Ben
Franklin
no I'm thinking the library system he
was the best writer in his he was the
best writer in his nation and also the
best scientist and also the best
inventor
where did that ever happened again yeah
yes yes all these other things yes so is
there a new edition of poor Charlie's on
he played four different musical
instruments everything else yeah that
part I did not know one of which he
invented which one she invented
the the glass thing that you know we
rubbing his fingers on the glass and it
was a they still played occasionally
yeah
with like different layers of water in
it but he actually played on four
different instruments
yeah and he was a diplomat and helped
yeah yeah no yeah right the rules of the
country
and taught us about compound interest
with the the trust that he set up for
both Philadelphia and for Boston that
still hundreds of years later are paying
out
no he he was a very amazing person and
of course the country was glad that we
were lucky to have him
is it true is there a new poor Charlie's
Almanac coming out
well they're creating an online edition
okay
you've talked about some by the way the
Chinese Edition sold way more than the
one in the United States
well there's more people there
that's not the sole reason why else
well
a rich old man looks like Confucius
in their system there's nothing better
than a rich old man yeah
uh Charlie sang Park writes in a
question and this is about delayed
gratification taken to the extreme how
rational is it for a person of your age
and wealth to practice delayed
gratification if it's not rational at
your age how is it rational to delay
gratification for the average adult so
what's the rational point in life to
live with no delayed gratification too
I'm still I'm still doing the now that
I'm old I buy these apartment houses it
gives me something to do
the way everybody else runs them
everybody else is trying to
show high income so they can high
distributions
we're trying to find ways to
intelligently spend money to make them
better
and and of course our Apartments do
better than other people do
because the man who runs them does it so
well for me
the man they're two young men that do it
with me and
and
but it's all deferred gratification
we're looking for opportunities to defer
other people are looking for ways to
enjoy it's a different way of going at
life
did you start out that way well you get
more enjoyment on my life doing it my
way than theirs what did you start out
um having to work at delayed
gratification or is that just how you
were born
no I I learned this trick early
and you know they've done that
experiment with the two marshmallows
with little kids
yeah and they've done
watch them how they work out in life by
now
and the delayed grass the little kids
who are good at deferring the
marshmallows are all also the people
that succeed in life
it's kind of sad that so much is inborn
so to speak
but you can learn it to some extent too
so
I'm gonna go home and test that out on
my kids
I was very lucky I I just naturally took
the Deferred gratification very early in
life and of course it's helped me ever
since
uh Matt McAllister writes in and says
first thank you for your sharing your
wisdom those of us fortunate enough to
listen have benefited significantly
we've come to know that Warren Buffett
we've come to know Warren Buffett as a
learning machine because of your candid
descriptions aside from this quality
what others would you credit to Warren
that has helped make him one of the
greatest investors and Compounders that
the world's ever seen
well
Warren is not only a very good good
thinker
and a good learner which is important
but Warren has a big strong fiduciary
Gene
he cares about what happens to the
shareholders
Warren and I were lucky and that the
early shareholders were people who
trusted us when we were young and didn't
have a reputation and so on and
naturally we feel an exceptional loyalty
to those people
and of course naturally they're all dead
now but we're still loyal to them I mean
I
Warren and I still care what happens to
the Berkshire shareholders a lot
and I think that helps us I I think that
it helps if you're
good at loyalty
go ahead Becky okay so Bala
therapanembakum writes in and and says
that many large companies including meta
which owns Facebook and various
insurances are choosing to self-insure
against liability either for directors
or for the business risks if it's
carried to extremes it would know as it
no doubt will be over time this could
cause potential systemic issues would
you share your thoughts on this please
he says he's been a shareholder of
Berkshire Hathaway for 16 years and
thanks you for your stewardship and
sharing your thoughts generously with
the younger Generations
in my own life I'm a big self-insurer
and so is Warren
it's ridiculous for me to carry fire
insurance on my houses because I can so
easily rebuild a house that would burn
down
so why would I want to bother fooling
around with the claims process and all
kinds of things
so if
insurance
you should ensure against
things you can't afford to pay for
yourself
but if you can afford to take the bumps
you know so unusual expense coming along
doesn't really hurt you that much
why would you want to fool around with
some insurance company if your house
burned down I would just write a check
and rebuild it
and
and all intelligent people do it my way
don't say all but
maybe I should say all intelligent
people should do it my way
there should be way more self-insurance
in life
there's a lot of waste you're paying
when you buy insurance for the other
fellows frauds
and there's a lot of fraud in life
and if you can afford to take the risk
yourself and not fool around with claims
and this and that and commissions and
time of course you did self-insurance
simpler and so forth
think of what I've saved in my life I
never
I don't care I never carried never I
think once I
but it was one exception I never carried
poison Insurance on a car
and once I got rich I stopped carrying
fire Insurance on houses
I just self-insure
it's a little bit of a surprising take
for the guys
that is the right way to do it
well that's a little bit of a surprising
take from a guy who's a vice chairman at
Berkshire which has so many insurance
companies
well but I'm not
I'd rather tell it the way it is and and
tell in a way that helps Berkshire
I'm not going to tell it differently
than I think it really is just because
it's better for Berkshire
even though it's bad for Berkshire I
want to tell you if you can afford to
self-insure self-insure
even on things like medical or I just
think you might think you could afford
these things no that is different your
insurer pays the doctor in the hospital
is a small fraction of what you pay so
that that's a different kind of calculus
everything in medicine is a
the cost of American Medical Care and
their medical insurance it's it's a
disgrace
if you go to Singapore you will find
that they do the whole thing better than
we do and it costs 20 percent of what we
pay
and again my audio and by the way I have
no idea of how to get from where we are
to where Singapore is because all the
people are getting all that extra money
fight like
Fierce Tigers to hold on to it
and they control boards and cities and
states and every other guy
so I don't I don't know how to fix the
costs an American
Health Care
they're totally out of control
and
i i Warren tried to fix it with Amazon
and all that stuff he failed to
everybody's failed with it
we everybody in America has a marvelous
record failing and handling
our cost of medicines
um
Matt McAllister writes in and I realized
he's asked a couple of questions I
didn't realize this was a repeat uh send
in but I like the questions he said what
are some of the most important things
that we need to know about Greg Abel
have you experienced examples of him
also being a learning machine and if so
could you share one
yeah well Greg is just sensational
at
being a business leader both as a
thinker and as a doer and he's also
sensationally good at smoothly getting
things done through other people
so he's a very remarkable human being
and Berkshire is very lucky to have him
and
and he's also is a tremendous learning
machine
you can argue that he's just as good as
Warren is learning all kinds of things
and one of the interesting things about
Greg is there's some things he's better
at than Warren is
and Martin knows that and he just keeps
dumping on the Greg
everything that Greg can do better and
it's a lot
and and so the system at Berkshire is
working pretty damn well we're very
lucky to have a 92 year old is good
shape as Warren and awareness and we're
very lucky to have us a chief executive
like
Greg Greg is very remarkable
Greg is trusted by Insurance regular by
uh utility regulators and rightly so
he is trying to run all those utilities
as if he were the regulator
now how many people think that way
but it's such a smart way to think
you mean just from a show of good faith
and
yeah why not please your
why not do it the way that you want it
done if you were on the other side of
the transaction how can you fail if you
treat other people well you'd like to be
treated to yourself
it's the golden rule of course it works
all right someone named Jim writes in
and
you know I asked this question because I
got a lot of similar ones just in terms
of Investments but this one
um is probably a question that a lot of
people as they start to get up 65 and
Beyond start to wonder he just says
would you recommend I take Social
Security when I'm 67 or wait till I'm 70
when I'll receive more per month
well I can't make that choice for you
it's it depends
if you know you're going to be dead
pretty soon I go ahead and
have more money to spend
you think you may live a long time you
may have a different calculus and
I would say that
most
most people who are healthy and so forth
and who have a pretty good life
expectancy
they're generally they're ways to defer
the Social Security taking and take more
money later
I guess it's optimistic thinking too if
you're thinking that you're going to
live a long time that's the way to play
it out
well what do you do Becky well I'm not
65 yet so I haven't thought about it yet
I'm waiting my guess is I would I would
probably work I don't think you're going
to need Social Security Becky I'm not
worried about you I think I would work
longer I'm naturally uh conservative so
um yeah
Le ping Wu young writes in you urge the
US government to ban cryptocurrencies as
China has done I have a more general
question with boom and bus Cycles in
different countries in history what
should a good government do and not do
for economic growth
well
you've got to do if you want
growing GDP per capita which is what
everybody should want
you've got to have
most of the property in private hands so
most of the people who are making
decisions about how properties do he
cared for on the property in question
and that makes the whole system so
efficient that GDP per capita grows
in a system where you have easy
exchanges due to a currency system and
so on
and so
that's the main way of of civilization
getting rich is having all these
exchanges and having all the property in
private hands
if you like violin lessons and I need
your money when we make a transaction
we're gaining on both sides
so of course GDP goes like goes like
crazy when you got a bunch of people who
are spending their own money and owning
their own businesses and so on
and and nobody in the history of the
world that I'm aware of has ever gotten
from hunter-gathering to Modern
civilization except through a system
where the
of where most of the property was
privately owned
hmm
a lot of freedom of Exchange
and
and by the way I just said something
that's perfectly obvious but hasn't
really taught that way in most education
even the you can take a course in
economics in college and not know what I
just said
they don't teach it exactly the same way
anyway
that would be your your best suggestion
yeah that okay yeah yeah okay
uh this one comes in from
Matt and he says throughout your
experience with Berkshire Hathaway what
are a few of the things that have
surprised you most based upon some of
your previous rational thoughts and
ideas also how have you used some of
those surprises in your quest to become
a better learning machine these are all
I would say the things that some of the
things that surprised me the most
oh
was how
how much dies
that the business world is very much
like the physical world
where all the animals die in the course
of improving all the species so they can
live in niches and so forth all the
animals die and eventually all the
species die that's the system
and when I was young I didn't realize
that that same system applied to what
happens in capitalism to all the
businesses
they're all on their way to dying is the
answer so other things can replace them
and live
and it causes some remarkable death
imagine having Kodak die
it was one of the great trademarks of
the world there was nobody who didn't
use film they dominated film they knew
more about the chemistry of film than
anybody else on Earth
and of course the whole damn business
went to zero
and
and look at Xerox was once owned the
world
it's just a pale shrinkage is nothing
compared to what it once was so
practically everything dies if you yeah
a big enough time scale when I was young
enough that was just as obvious then
I didn't see it for a while
you know things that looked Eternal and
been around for a long time I thought
wouldn't likely be that way when I was
old
but a lot of them have disappeared
practically everything dies in business
none of the Eminence lasts forever
think of all the great department stores
think of how long they were the most
important thing in their little
community
they're way ahead of everybody in
Furnishing credit convenience in all
seasons
you know convenience back and forth you
the same Banks of elevators and so forth
multiple floors it looked like they were
eternal
and they're basically all dying
or dead
and so that
once I understood that better
I think it made me a better investment
investor I think
I mean the same can be said for for
managers I've talked with Doug McMillan
of Walmart who carries around in his
wallet like on him he carries around a
list of the top retailers over the
decades and nobody's ever the same you
know yes we're gone yes yes of course
yeah retailers live in Terror
because you can die someone got some
that's a better way of doing it
you just die
like those department stores did
the ones that you invested in early on
you mean
the Baltimore
well no most of the think of the
department stores that are gone just
chain after chain after chain big
downtown
that they're not
weakened that they're gone dead
and
and to have IBM have a huge position at
once had in terms of utter dominance
and now it's just one of the also Iran's
and it's still an admirable place I'm
sure they have a lot of talent left in
IBM
it doesn't help you you die even though
you're talented and hardworking
author Khan writes in and he's a Daily
Journal shareholder who lives in Toronto
he says Mr Munger while many of us
admire you and look up to you I want to
ask who were some of the people you most
admired and looked up to what was it
about them that made them so special
well
um some of the best people
I would argue that Jim Senegal at Costco
was about as well adapted for the
executive here he got
and by the way he didn't go to Wharton
he didn't go to the Harvard Business
School he started work at age 18 in a
store
and he rose to be CEO at Costco
in effect he was a founder
under a man named Saul price
and
I would argue that what he accomplished
in his own lifetime was one of the most
remarkable things in the whole history
of business in the history of the world
Jim Senegal in his life
he's still very much alive but he's
but he
he had a
one business throughout his whole life
basically
he just got so damn good at it there was
apparently nothing he didn't understand
large or small
and
there aren't that many gem senegals
I'll tell you somebody else for a job
that of the kind he has
Greg Abel in a way
is just as good as Greg sentenced
Senegal was
yeah he has the kind of a genius for the
way he handles people and so forth and
problems
and
I can't tell you how I admire somebody
that has enough sense to kind of
roughly as utilities
and so he were the regulator
he's not trying to
pass on the cost because he can do it
he's trying to
he's trying to do it the way he'd want
it done if he were the regulator instead
of the executive of course that's the
right way to run a utility
but how many are really run that way
so there's some admirable business
people out there and I've been lucky to
have quite a few of them
involved in my life the guy who ran TTI
was a genius
TT is the Berkshire subsidiary
a New Delhi Journal people think how
lucky you'd be if we still had our
Monopoly on publishing our cases or
something we'd be like TTI well TTI has
just marched some triumphs of Triumph
and it was run by a guy he got fired and
created the business
I got fired from where he invented the
whole
uh General some place the defense
contractor I forget which one General
Dynamic Maybe
I can't remember exactly
but he was a terrific guy
and
and he ran the business for us he
wouldn't let us raise his pay
how many people have the problem with
their managers they won't let them they
won't allow you to raise their pay it's
pretty rare foreign
yeah
Charlie I spoke with a friend of yours
yesterday and his question that he had
for you is what quality has helped you
the most in life
well that's easy rationality
if you're just not crazy you have a big
advantage over 95 percent of the people
because most people have all kinds of
crazy patches
and if you just are consistently not
crazy you had a you had a big advantage
in life
and here patient and uh
gratification defer in addition to being
not crazy then it's practically a cinch
and then if you're exceptionally good at
satisfying your commitments to other
people
then you've got
you you just automatically improved your
resources and your chances in life
enormously and it's so simple
and why don't more people do it
it's an interesting question I don't
think you can educate your children to
do it automatically
that's why you have 10 children you'll
have some that are a lot better than
others doing this
is it harder with success age wealth to
hold on to rationality
I think it's
it's always hard but you get better at
it if you
get good at Young and keep practicing
but it's it's never easy
if you had to that question somebody
asked what one stock would you buy if
you had to just rely on that one stock
only
for for your sole living expenses
you weren't allowed to have any or any
income at all you just had to invest a
million dollars and live on that one
stock
how many people would give an
intelligent answer to that question in
America
I don't think it's one in a hundred
I think they wouldn't even know how to
begin
I think one of my favorite things that
I've heard you say and it's something I
repeat often to a lot of people is
whatever you are age and wealth makes
you more so
um
came up with that a while ago what led
you to that you have a course yeah do
you have any I guess I think that's true
that we all tend to
we all we we all tend to
get a little more so in every way
and
uh
I thought of that when I
woke up this morning and put on my
trousers on
I thought you know I really economized
in buying those trousers
you know why am I economizing in my
trouser buying all right
yeah but it's just
so ingrained I can't stop
and
I'd like to Circle back to a question on
Daily Journal to wrap things up Daily
Journal and some of your Holdings this
question comes in from Moshi Sable who
says in a previous shareholder meeting
back around 2018 you spoke about byd and
said Journal Technologies is not quite
byd but added that by the way it might
work out just like byd now a few years
on do you still find Journal
Technologies can turn out similar to byd
well it won't be as fast that I
guarantee you
and I won't be as great I can also
frankly guarantee that
ability is one of the most remarkable
Venture Capital successes in the history
of the world
he was the eighth son of a peasant
had an older brother that recognized his
young kid was kind of a younger brother
was a genius and the older brothers
sacrificed himself to get this
peasant Sun into some good engineering
school and he became an engineering
professor and then an entrepreneur
and
how many times you get a story like that
and imagine buying a little bankrupt
Auto
company in China and turning it into
something that that
this year they're going to sell more
electrical cars than anybody else in the
world
at a time when electric guitars are hot
and
it's a remarkable story but again a very
unusual human being want chunpoo
and by the way
in his case it wouldn't have happened if
Juan John Foo hadn't been so unusual
unusual how he's a goddamn he's a damn
genius and he's been thinking about the
right things 17 hours a day all his life
he's a workaholic and
he he can do things that ordinary human
beings can't do
is that the favorite stock you've ever
purchased byd
or Costco
well I would say
yes I have never helped do anything in
Berkshire that was as good as byd and I
only did it once
our our 270 000 investment there is
worth about 8 billion now or maybe nine
and
that's a pretty good rate of return yeah
more than pretty good
okay
yeah yeah we we don't do it all the time
we do it once in a lifetime
now we have to add some other successes
too but
but I don't think hardly anything like
that
we made one better investment you know
what it was
we paid an executive recruiter to get us
a
an employee and he came up with a heat
chain
yeah the return that Ajit has made us
compared to the amount we paid the
executive recruiter that was our best
investment at Berkshire which was I'm
paying the executive recruiting for him
to get a get a side street chain but
again it only happened once
yeah that's uh quite an investment too
Charlie I just want to thank you for all
your time today all right we're all
through I guess and being so generous I
guess our meeting is over and we'll turn
it back over I'm still here to do one
more with you people
we've been at this quite a few years
so my best to all of you bye
thanks everyone
thank you Becky thank you Stephen thank
you Charlie